what is this site about
what do we propose here
we propose nothing less
than the total overhaul
of the scientific method
we argue that science itself has been
misconceived misconstrued
from the start
first by the ancient greeks
and then by the generation
that kick-started the 17th century
so-called
scientific revolution
time to take a deep breath now
[Music]
the university of berkeley understanding
science site synthesizes for us in
notions of science that we ended up with
today
since the scientific revolution of the
17th century
essentially science is both a body of
knowledge and an ongoing process of
discovery and science is useful because
it can help us develop new technologies
and yet this prominent university site
lists what causes gravity as one of the
questions that no one using the
contemporary scientific method has been
able to answer in the last 400 years
after 400 years
now how difficult can this be
how is this possible
how is it possible that no think tank on
the planet can be able to figure this
kindergarten stuff out
i mean what do we have
we have the earth
and we have the moon
two rocks
and no one can tell you
why the moon remains faithful to our
planet and doesn't spontaneously fly
away
out of the solar system
so if contemporary so-called science
cannot answer such a simple question
after 400 years maybe there's something
wrong with the notion of science that we
have
maybe the scientific method that we've
been using
is not the one that conduces to such
answers
is science a body of knowledge
is it an ongoing process of discovery
is science supposed to be useful
is the purpose of science to develop new
technologies
does science have anything at all to do
with technology does science have
anything to do with math
the layman seeks something else
they don't care about equations what
they want to understand is the
mechanisms that underlie gravity
magnetism and other such invisible
phenomena
does the current scientific method meet
those expectations
we're going to argue here
that it's time for a major paradigm
shift
[Music]
you